hello freak [ __ ] yeah 2005 that was
our last ever wild boys trip oh yeah
yeah and we brought a Knoxville with us
knock so we had some like Russian army
kind of Dayton dudes and and then Knox
was like shoot me with the 9-millimeter
gun with the rubber bullet while the dog
bites me what yeah he was he was going
for it and and and our director Jeff
Tremaine was like hey if you still have
this in you why don't we not do it for
TV let's make another movie and that was
why we stopped doing wild boys and made
jackass number two if you still have
this in you oh I just don't want to get
it beaten with rubber bullets do we a
lot of [ __ ] happen on that [ __ ] that
last wild boys trip man there is that we
always we had this practice of like for
the censors you know it's called
standards and practices they'll be like
you know they'll give back notes like
you can't you know show this and so we
would film what we call red herrings
like just blatantly ridiculous [ __ ] and
never a lot never gonna be allowed on TV
but then we'll be like okay well we'll
cut this out and so then we'll be able
to keep some other [ __ ] right so we
would always go out of our way to film
this [ __ ] up stuff and in Russia we me
and one of the guys from that from the
crew would put like put on these animal
suits the what was it at the time it
wasn't panda bears polar bears with a
big [ __ ] like mascot head and we
[ __ ] hired two hookers and had
full-on [ __ ] hookers came in like
full of porno we felt before [ __ ] we
included we included that in the episode
you know and the notes came back from
standards and practices I can't really
please like that you have to take out
the you know the [ __ ] he had the
polar bear getting his dick sucked like
that the whole thing yeah and there was
a little bit of [ __ ] hooker action in
that one you know and I'm not
necessarily that stoked about it but
there was we went to it we went to like
a whorehouse brought this hooker back to
the hotel right is there like a whole
thing
then in in the and and I don't think I
ever could have even have sex with a
with a hooker without like snuggling
after I want to like snot snuggle and
smelling you know oh my godness stay
with me I want to like you know cuddle
and stuff and in the morning this this
hooker she just tells me like how much
how much I owe her right and I'm like
that's [ __ ] outrageous there's no
[ __ ] away I was like sighs like
basically I don't care if your [ __ ]
pimp wants to kick my ass and [ __ ]
kill me I'm not paying that [ __ ] much
that's not much that's why I forget it
was so long ago but but yeah I was
outraged
so that was negotiated before him it
just it just wasn't in that case exactly
I remember clearly I was like you want
that much and I said I said I'll give
you this much and that's how much you
get weird and we came out right like you
know I got a go film and walking through
the lobby Knoxville's down there having
breakfast this hooker comes walking by
knocks alone she says that's not Steve
oh that's cheapo that much into like
hookers but but but you know in looking
back on I guess I really [ __ ] kind of
had sex that bunch of hookers because I
had this girlfriend and you know like I
work a program of recovery I gotta be
honest and [ __ ] and I had this
girlfriend she was an English chick and
she says have you ever had sex for the
prostitute I'm like oh [ __ ] you know and
I tell her we talk about you know I
never did until I was in England one
time and you know II did this Gumball
Rally where you race cars with all the
rich guys and you know they're getting
hookers and they they got me one and
yeah I brought her though I told her the
whole story about how I was I couldn't
give me a massage
she's giving me a back rub and this
hooker says this is one expensive back
rub and I felt like she was making fun
of me it's not [ __ ] I put on some
Motley Crue and put on her
and I humped her okay you know I told
this story to my girlfriend she says
it's okay what did you was there any
other ones and I'm like ah [ __ ] you know
I'm like well in New Zealand you know
like there was a massage parlor and it
turned out that that they just have sex
with you you know like an and it's a
joke you know I was like I didn't I've
like I felt like I was having sex of the
prostitute but she was a masseuse like
there's not another one and I'm like wow
there's a time in Indonesia no just kept
rolling on yeah and the thing was at
that exact time we were like she
arranged this trip to go to Cornwall
it's a little surf town in England
because I like collect pictures with you
know of different countries where you
know I call it my surf passport and I'm
like I want to get a surfing photo so I
can include England she's like she says
I know why you're making a surf Passport
you should have a [ __ ] hooker
passport
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]